alright guys you want some cool exciting
news cool exciting news is what I bring
so as you've all seen a read on the
internet people are really pissed off
about the Oscars a lot of people feel a
lot of snubs have happened like a lot of
people should have been nominated that
weren't nominated at all I for one feel
that way hence my Husker snubs video so
the schmoes from schmoes know and I
talked about it we were like why
about it when you can actually do
something you know proactive it's what
keeps the world turn it so we thought
why not give the people an awards show
that's for them not a bunch of
pretentious douche bags that live in
Hollywood so we decided we're gonna
bring you guys the you reviewers movie
awards now we know a few people are
probably thinking sweet a few
Christopher Nolan fans are pissed off
that Christopher Nolan didn't get
nominated so they're gonna give him
awards and it's actually not like that
yeah if I could theorize right now I
think he's probably gonna get nominated
we got together with a bunch of
reviewers like a really diverse group
like me the schmoes theory the film fan
Tom chattel bash chris stuckmann a bunch
of others like a fellowship of reviewers
really and they'll present also so it'll
be a lot of fun you'll see a lot of
familiar faces and we're going to vote
on it I have no idea how the votes are
going to turn out it's a mystery kind of
anxious to see though votes will be
tallied up then we'll have the
nominations I'll announce the
nominations on my channel so be sure to
watch out for that and then I'd say a
few days before the Oscars you got to
snipe the Oscars moes knowing myself
jeremyjahns will bring you the you
reviewers Movie Awards well bring it to
you guys and we'll take Awards back for
you guys if you haven't already
subscribed to the schmoes subscribe 2
i'll put a link right there yes we've
done the Oscar collaborations but now
it's time to be proactive for you guys
we're going to take Awards back for you
the people we want to make this a really
big deal so tell your friends tell your
family blog about it right about it make
videos about it tell them to subscribe
to us and you guys will actually get an
award show that you can relate to I
don't know about you but we're sick and
tired of this political and
this will be an annual thing 2011 just
the beginning this is year one yeah
we're not stopping this is the prelude
and be sure to check back here in a
couple days i'll have the announcements
for the nominees for the you reviewers
award show and of course if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more